that's the nastiest thing you've seen on  the internet I recently went on [ __ ]  H3 and Ethan showed me a video of two  prolapsed [ __ ] rubbing against each  other I mean it was like I haven't felt  that jarring like holy [ __ ] why did he  show you that hey that's a great  question he's just out of nowhere well  no there is a backstory you know Howie  Mandel's Tick Tock that yeah yes yeah  yeah yeah what was that one again he  just looked at the camera like look at  this prolapse no he said is this coven  related and if so what do we do about it  his prolapsed [ __ ] right  um it wasn't his oh it was his it was  his own yeah Oh I thought no it wasn't  it was Ethan's  just spreading rumors  in front of Ethan h3s plural Labs  [ __ ] that is crazy